what was uh Chris Bosh like
he was in that mug chilling and he was
making beats he was telling everybody my
name Chris
we know buddy yeah nah but like yeah one
of my homies did we was on some funny
[ __ ] we on some Christmas looking ass
[ __ ] like you know what I'm saying we
looking at them but to your friend one
of my homies didn't think he was really
Chris by so he just like oh you you guys
were like yo look at this Chris Bosh
looking muffin yeah he like Chris but
yeah we fried like this ain't Christmas
[ __ ] you don't rap yeah but I guess you
do well he raps I think he produced he
he tapped in how were the Beats I ain't
heard no Chris Bosh beats hmm I want to
hear some Chris Bosh but you know who
has a NBA producer who has some of the
worst beats I've ever heard that made it
on the major labels or major albums
Chris Webber he had a daughter he had a
beat on Nas's uh hip-hop is dead album
that was so atrocious
you know what's funny is I'm from the
West Coast so God I was a little more
popular on the West Coast
but I never I never could do it the
anti-speed that was the Latrell spree
with the Spree Wheels yeah that was an
error yeah Supreme
I had no doubt uh you didn't have any uh
you know I mean you know there you know
who's dope JaVale McGee's a dope
producer Javale McGee cool peoples bro
and he's got dope beats yeah down there
in Phoenix right now right not anymore
he's with the Mavericks now I'm a Sons
yeah he got signed in the offseason
unfortunately this this year yeah yeah
this off season yeah oh that's cool but
um I know that [ __ ] might be but it
made sense he had hit me up before just
on some like what's good but I feel like
everybody in the lead that hit me up
they probably make music now that I
think about it that's hard for sure what
is your team in St Louis
the Celtics that's interesting the St
Louis Celtics yeah you know how we
coming man I was at the finals game last
year man my my boy JT you know I'm
saying we ain't we ain't bringing home
but we're gonna bring her home next time
you know I'm saying aside I mean listen
man the coaches out there bringing it
home for sure
hey man I don't know what to say bro
anyway I don't know what to say bro hey
eBay's outside bro I mean he's gonna be
outside on the couch but you know God
bless him
cause that boy got money he good yeah
you're right it's a nice couch yeah a
bellini for sure on a bellini coach